on april 3rd 2007 kyle vogt tweeted
hacking away on video code no one knew
it at the time but kyle had just started
building the live streaming service that
would eventually become twitch every
overnight success actually has a 10-year
journey behind it well it's been over a
decade since kyle became an entrepreneur
and he's now raised 10 billion dollars
to build a fleet of driverless taxis at
his latest company cruz the story of how
kyle went from dropping out of mit to
co-founding twitch and then to working
on self-driving cars is a classic
example of grit and determination paying
off in a big way after years of
sleepless nights and it all starts with
a locked safe in the basement of his
university dorm
[Music]
kyle had grown up in a suburban part of
kansas and had always been passionate
about robotics so when he got the chance
to go and study computer science and
electrical engineering at mit he jumped
at the opportunity while at mit kyle was
constantly solving robotics challenges
he interned at irobot the company that
makes the roomba vacuum cleaner he
competed in a self-driving car
competition that essentially spawned the
entire autonomous vehicle industry and
even before college he had built robots
to compete in two separate battlebots
events at just 13 years old so when his
friend discovered a locked safe in a
dusty basement on the mit campus kyle
knew that they had to build a robot to
crack it open
now most people would just go get a
blowtorch or maybe just ignore the safe
entirely but kyle is a true engineer and
wanted a challenge it was the middle of
winter and a particularly harsh boston
snowstorm had blanketed the campus there
wasn't much going on outside so kyle and
his friends spent weeks building a
device to open the safe they settled on
an auto dialer which would brute force
the combination by entering every
possible number one at a time the device
was clunky and needed huge magnets to
attach to the front of the safe but it
worked the auto dialer iterated through
hundreds of combinations before finally
hitting the correct sequence of numbers
the safe swung open and kyle was finally
able to claim his prize but before we
talk about what was in the safe we need
to address another key moment in kyle's
time at mit during kyle's junior year he
started talking with a silicon valley
entrepreneur named justin khan justin
had already sold one tech company and
was looking for engineers to help him
with a new project the idea was to build
a website that would host a live stream
of justin's life and this project would
eventually become twitch kyle had no way
to predict how big of a success twitch
would be but he had four weeks of free
time coming up during mit's regularly
scheduled independent activities period
taking a break from school to go build
some interesting technology with
experienced silicon valley entrepreneurs
seemed like a low-risk bet so kyle
signed on he immediately fell in love
with the technical challenges in front
of him so he deferred his enrollment at
mit and started building the future of
live streaming full-time these days
every social media platform has a live
streaming option but back then serving
real-time video over the internet
required cutting-edge skills as the
product evolved from justin's individual
stream to community streams and then
eventually to gaming streams kyle was
focused on scaling the underlying
technology and you can see how hard he
was working from his tweets during this
period of time in april of 2009 he
improved site performance by 57 with a
new database tool then just five months
later he was struggling with more
scaling issues basically whenever the
team ran into a difficult technical
issue kyle would step up and do whatever
it took to fix the problem there's a
period of probably 18 months where i had
normalized going to bed and then like
waking up at 4am whenever like the
traffic would spike in in europe and
like spend an hour and a half to two
hours battling server fires and then
like pass out that was like every single
day seven days a week for like 18 months
it was clearly hard work but it wound up
paying off massively twitch ultimately
sold to amazon for nearly a billion
dollars and kyle had proven himself not
only as an engineer but also as an
entrepreneur there was a problem though
kyle had made a lot of money but that
was never his primary motivation he was
obsessed with solving engineering
challenges remember this is a guy who
spent three weeks cracking a safe when
he had no idea what was inside of it he
wasn't interested in just collecting a
big check from jeff bezos and then
sitting on a beach somewhere he was on
the hunt for his next safe to crack
twitch might have felt like an overnight
success from the outside but kyle had
spent years working tirelessly to make
live streaming a reality he had learned
that startups are marathons not sprints
so he decided on three key criteria that
he would use to decide what to work on
next i wanted to use you know the skills
i had as an engineer and developed to do
something good the second one is it had
to have extremely hard technical
problems that needed to be solved
because i know that's what engages me
and keeps me motivated and the third one
is it had to be a good business because
to actually achieve that positive social
impact you need scale self-driving
technology was a perfect fit because it
satisfied all three of kyle's rules it
could save lives by reducing car
accidents it required cutting-edge
engineering to work and had the
potential to impact the entire
transportation market the only problem
was everyone thought it would be
impossible for a startup to build a
self-driving car it was clearly an
incredibly expensive endeavor and google
was already years ahead if kyle was
going to build a self-driving car
company it would mean staking his entire
reputation on the project he had built
up enough credibility to raise money for
basically any idea he wanted so he
decided to cash it all in at once and
shoot for the moon
kyle had decided to take on one of the
biggest tech companies in the world and
he knew he couldn't do it alone so he
started assembling his team first he
joined up with daniel khan justin khan's
brother to co-found the business then he
joined y combinator and started really
building the company which the team was
now calling cruz at the time y
combinator wasn't really known as a
place to go and build hardware startups
airbnb and dropbox were the most
high-profile alumni companies but things
were about to change one yc founder
named oliver cameron had started working
at udacity and was rolling out a
self-driving car class that would be
open to anyone with an internet
connection all of a sudden engineers
from all over the world were starting to
build their own autonomous vehicles this
educational program was really
transformative for the industry people
were realizing that building a
self-driving car was inevitable and
engineers were starting to learn the
necessary skills to join the new
industry google had already hired most
of the self-driving car experts so kyle
and his team needed a way to
differentiate they knew that it would be
impossible to go head-to-head with
google and build a fully autonomous car
immediately so they settled on a hybrid
approach while it was certainly
impressive to demonstrate a google car
that didn't even have a steering wheel
that project was taking too long to get
to market every year there would be tons
of articles about how the google
self-driving car was right around the
corner and then every year it would fail
to ship kyle and his team wanted to get
something into the hands of consumers as
soon as possible so they settled on an
aftermarket kit that could modify a car
to add some self-driving functionality
the initial specifications were pretty
narrow it only worked on the audi a4 and
it could only help with highway driving
but it actually worked and people were
eager to buy it it was an important
milestone for the company and kyle was
able to take reporters for test rides in
2014. cruz was still far from launching
a commercially available self-driving
car but the fact that they had managed
to launch the highway drive assist
products so quickly was incredibly
promising investors started to think
that crews really had a shot at beating
google but soon it became clear that the
audi modification strategy needed a
massive overhaul see strapping some
cruise equipment to the top of an audi
made sense as a prototype but there was
just too much risk to this approach if
crews started rolling it out to more car
brands when it comes to something that
has safety critical implications like
controlling the steering and the other
control inputs on your car it's pretty
hard to get there with with a
retrofitter there's basically an
infinite list of long tail issues that
can get you and if you're dealing with a
safety critical product that's not
really acceptable so kyle and his team
at cruz were going to have to figure out
how to build their own self-driving cars
from scratch it was really the only way
that the team could guarantee that
critical systems would behave as
expected but building a new automotive
company is far from easy only two major
car companies have avoided bankruptcy in
the history of the united states tesla
and ford and these businesses are
incredibly capital intensive so the only
option for kyle was to find a company to
partner with fortunately general motors
had been looking for a way to position
themselves in the self-driving car
industry and they weren't particularly
interested in building a team from
scratch partnership between gm and crews
would solve problems for both companies
kyle and the cruise team would get
access to the manufacturing plants
needed to mass-produce self-driving cars
and gm would be able to transfer the
self-driving technology to their fleet
it seemed like a win-win but this was a
big moment for kyle since he had seen
twitch get absorbed into the amazon
corporate structure would he still be
able to satisfy his life goals of
working on something impactful
challenging and scalable inside of a 100
year old car company or would he burn
out and leave as soon as his shares
vested it wasn't a decision to take
lightly because starting from scratch at
this point would be incredibly difficult
see if gm acquired cruz and then failed
to really back the self-driving car
project all of kyle's work would be for
nothing and leaving to start a new
self-driving car company probably
wouldn't be an option either because of
all the legal red tape from the
acquisition but kyle realized that gm
needed crews as much as crews needed gm
so they struck a deal
in 2016
gm acquired cruz for around a billion
dollars it was an incredible financial
outcome for everyone involved since the
company was only a few years old but for
kyle it only raised the stakes further
he now had to deliver a fully
self-driving car to the public and he
only had a few years to do it
google was far from the only competitor
at this point tesla was planning on
adding self-driving functionality to all
of their new models and uber had built
an entire research team dedicated to
autonomous vehicles smaller startups
were starting to carve out niches in the
industry too comma ai had doubled down
on their own retrofit strategy and
oliver cameron the yc alum who worked on
the self-driving program at udacity
wound up launching his own driverless
car startup named voyage oliver had been
particularly focused on creating
user-friendly ride-sharing services at
voyage and had rolled out self-driving
cars in retirement communities as
competition heated up in the industry
the public started asking more questions
about the long-term implications of this
new technology specifically one peculiar
thought experiment began coming up again
and again the trolley problem the
problem usually goes something like this
imagine that you're driving down a
freeway in a self-driving car and you
get boxed in on all sides by other
vehicles then all of a sudden something
huge falls off the truck directly in
front of you there's no way that your
car can stop in time to avoid hitting
the object entirely so the ai needs to
make a decision do nothing and smash
into the object swerve left into an suv
or swerve right into a motorcycle should
the car prioritize your safety by
hitting the motorcycle minimize danger
to others by not swerving even if it
means hitting the object from the truck
and sacrificing your life or take the
middle ground by hitting the suv which
has a high passenger safety rating and
the question is what should the
self-driving car do in that situation
these ethical questions became
incredibly popular mostly because
they're just so interesting to talk
about but they're built upon one common
misconception about self-driving cars
when people think about autonomous
vehicles or really any robotic system
they tend to think that programmers are
mapping out every single action as a set
of rules but that's actually not how it
works here's how one of the cruise team
members put it everyone talks about the
trolley problem that's the most asked
question i get every time i do an
interview and i think it's a little
silly because if you're ever in that
position to begin with something is
wrong it's certainly thought provoking
to imagine a situation where an engineer
has to write a specific rule in code to
address the trolley problem but in
reality the system is just going to be
continuously trying to avoid collisions
of any kind and the only reason these
autonomous systems have begun to work as
well as they have is because of a
revolution in machine learning that
removes the need for those types of
hand-coded rules this new machine
learning creates new problems though it
requires an immense amount of data that
data really isn't too difficult to
gather though you can just attach
equipment to cars and drive around
gathering images of the city streets the
problem is labeling that data the
companies that exist today if you're
going to go to them and say i want a
million miles of driving every every bit
of data from that drive annotated by
humans i think that would be billions of
dollars so crews came up with a few
interesting solutions here kyle and his
team created a system that auto labels
the data by drawing connections between
various images maps and other data
sources solving the problem of data
labeling at scale is hard work but it's
exactly where kyle thrives and his team
has made significant advances here even
creating an entire 3d city simulation to
help generate extra driving scenarios
for testing autonomous systems succeed
or fail based on the data that they're
given so naturally you'd think that more
data is always better but not everyone
agrees with that kyle and his team added
lidar sensors to cruise vehicles in
order to feed their systems as much
information as possible every second but
it was a controversial move now to be
clear lidar is a well established
technology when the spacex dragon
capsule is docking with the
international space station it's using a
lidar system to detect the exact
distance between the capsule in the
station it's an incredibly precise
technology and when you're building a
million dollar rocket you can afford to
use the best sensors available but elon
musk has some strong opinions about
using lidar in self-driving cars lidar
is is a fool's errand and anyone relying
on lidar is doomed that's a pretty
aggressive condemnation of lidar and
people tend to pay attention when elon
makes a bold pronouncement like that but
it's important to unpack what he really
means there elon made that comment
during a tesla event focused on
self-driving technology and his argument
against lidar was primarily focused on
the cost of each unit individual lidar
sensors can easily cost tens of
thousands of dollars so adding them to
cars designed for everyday consumers
just doesn't make economic sense elon
had been working for over a decade now
to drop the price of electric vehicles
to a point where anyone can afford them
adding expensive sensors to each car was
fundamentally incompatible with his
long-term plan but kyle saw things
differently and had developed a unique
strategy at cruz kyle and his team had
already seen promising results from
using lidar to detect objects around
cruise vehicles and they believed that
the price of lidar would fall so they
acquired a company named strobe to build
the next generation of lidar sensors the
strobe team had been working on
collapsing the entire lidar sensor down
into a single chip which would
dramatically reduce the cost of each
unit second and perhaps most importantly
kyle had crafted a significantly
different business model from elon tesla
was focused on building cars that could
be sold directly to consumers so they
had to be affordable crews on the other
hand would focus on deploying
self-driving cars through ride sharing
and delivery services with this new
strategy kyle and his team announced the
crew's origin in january of 2020. it's
not a product you buy it's an experience
you share the crew's origin really made
it clear to everyone in the industry
that kyle and elon were taking two
completely distinct paths to solve
self-driving this new vehicle from crews
didn't even have a steering wheel and
was designed to drive for 1 million
miles the goal was clear create a
driverless car that was entirely owned
and operated by crews everyday commuters
wouldn't even be able to buy this new
car so all of a sudden the price per
vehicle could be a lot higher and still
make economic sense for crews but even
though kyle didn't have plans to sell
these vehicles directly to the public he
still had to design a product that
consumers would love
[Music]
at this point in time lots of skeptics
had written off self-driving cars as a
fool's errand and claimed that true
self-driving would never arrive pressure
was building as more and more
self-driving car companies started to
miss their announced launch dates and it
didn't help that kyle had previously
stated that crews would launch in 2019
cynical takes were pouring in left and
right and every day was critical now
kyle had accomplished so much but what
would it take to finally get across the
finish line he'd built an incredible
team struck a critical partnership with
gm raised billions of dollars and
delivered a truly world-class
self-driving experience but actually
releasing it to the public would require
even more hard work and sleepless nights
kyle wanted to deliver affordable and
reliable ride sharing using crew's
autonomous vehicles and he needed to
grow the team to do it fortunately
oliver cameron had been building this
exact type of service for years now at
voyage now oliver had focused voyage on
servicing retirement communities
specifically and if voyage could figure
out how to let 80 year old retirees use
self-driving cars reliably they could
definitely figure out how to deliver a
great product to san franciscans so kyle
acquired oliver's company voyage and
gave him the title of vp of product it
was go time kyle had to deliver a
polished product by the end of 2021 or
else the entire project could start to
lose steam the team worked tirelessly
and on november 3rd 2021 it finally
happened
i'm about to do my first driverless ride
ever in san francisco kyle and his team
had finally delivered there was no
safety driver ready to take over if
something went wrong there was no remote
control of the vehicle from cruise hq
and they were driving in san francisco
one of the most confusing cities in
america but it worked
that was so smooth so cool it just
worked that was uh i was amazing i don't
know what to say thank you cruz you guys
made this happen now kyle's journey is
clearly far from over and cruz has tons
more milestones to hit before
self-driving cars are truly ubiquitous
but i'm incredibly optimistic for one
major reason and it all comes back to
that safe in the mit basement
see most people who set out to crack a
safe do it for what's inside they don't
really care about how they got the safe
open all that matters is the reward but
that's just not how kyle's brain works
he's focused on the journey and has an
intrinsic love of problem solving that's
why when he mentioned the story of the
mit safe during an interview he didn't
even address what was inside the safe
the contents of the safe don't matter
what matters is the journey required to
open the safe in a few years when we're
all regularly riding in self-driving
cars i'm sure the experience's novelty
will fade but kyle will be out there
focused on an entirely new technical
challenge just enjoying the process of
cracking the next safe
thanks for watching this if you're
looking for another amazing story about
an automotive entrepreneur go check out
this video where i explain why one of
tesla's co-founders quit the company to
start a new startup